well let me first start by paying
tribute to Nicolas sturgeon for her
long-standing public service and I wish
her well in the future now obviously
Nicola and I didn't agree on everything
but in the short time that we did work
together I was pleased that we were able
to announce to Freeport in Scotland
that's joint working between the UK
government and the Scottish government
those free ports are going to attract
investment and create jobs in Scotland
which is great and I look forward to
working with whoever the new first
minister is to continue working
constructively to deliver for the people
of Scotland
she's been a an incredibly powerful
effective Force for uh Independence in
Scotland without her
is that a huge blow for the independence
movement and conversely is that a boost
in your view for the union well I've
consistently said that I think what
people in Scotland want to see is their
two governments a Scottish government
and the UK government working
constructively together on the
priorities that really matter to people
and that's about reducing inflation
increasing our energy security driving
growth and creating jobs across the
United Kingdom yet that's what people's
priorities are and that's what I will
continue to do and work on with whoever
the new first minister is